avec notre projet les seniors vont
pouvoir retrouver de la mobilité gagne
en autonomie
beaucoup de européenne à se déplacer à
cause de l'absence de réseau de
transport et la demande des grands axes
de circulation associées au
vieillissement de la population
produisent un isolement des plus
fragiles pour est comment donc leur
garantie aux transports aux pirates et
de proximité
nous disons stop à la débrouille et nous
proposons un service de transport
solidaire 100% écologique et pas cher
jacques se mettant sur simple appel
pouvoir bénéficier de véhicules
électriques avec chauffeur pour tous
types de déplacements tout en
privilégiant la convivialité hockey
musée isolement conserver l'autonomie
favoriser le contact humain crée de
l'emploi répondent à un besoin urgent de
mobilité tout en ayant un bilan carbone
intéressant c'est ce que vivent et qu'on
taxi seigneurie à l'éthique
[Musique]